we've I think done about five or maybe
even six videos counting the extra bits
in this area of information theory and a
little bit of coding theory and we got
to a reasonably good state with this but
the story needs finishing off so I'd
like to finish off the story and go back
to our old example of San Francisco
weather States I'll try and make this
completely understandable in a
free-standing way but if you do get a
bit lost go to the playlist and just
catch up with a bits and pieces that
you're not quite sure about what we've
done here is split them up into four
good codes that are meaningful and four
bad ones we've been working for ages now
with this very accurate model of San
Francisco weather that it's either foggy
sunny cloudy or rainy and you get about
25 percent of each of those states so
the probabilities a quarter
it's a 2-bit code foggy 0/0 sunny 0-1
cloudy one zero
rainy one one fine four states four
different bit patterns two bits needed
what we I think then did right at the
very end was this what happens if you
get a disturbance electrical disturbance
on the line which either turns a 0 into
a 1 or a 1 into a zero now this is a
good stage or which to say something
which I've never actually emphasized
before we're assuming what Claude
Shannon calls a symmetric channel in
other words there is as if a bit gets
clobbered it could be a zero turning
into a 1 or it could be a 1 turning into
a zero but if that happens it's equally
probable either way in other words
there's nothing about a 1 bit that makes
it different from a 0 bit in terms of
its noise immunity so it's a binary
symmetric channel we said all right
letters add 1/3 a bit to these 2 bit
codes and let us keep what's called the
overall parity even in other words it
must be an even number of 1
so here we go look what could you add to
two zeros there's a third bit on the
right and still keep it even parity well
it's even parity already so you can add
to zero if you send three bits then so
long has they arrived looking like one
of these patterns that's fine but then
you get things like oh well suppose at
Sacramento they get zero one zero that's
not one of these four so what does zero
one zero tells you well it told you that
something went wrong because it's not in
the allowed set but the problem is
there's no end of way is that zero one
zero could have arisen so you can detect
but you can't correct then we got on to
talking about how would Sacramento say
back to San Francisco I got it I love it
or not acknowledge I don't like it it's
a bad code so we invented AK an AK back
from Sacramento to San Francisco and
then you go through the same argument
finally we said what do we have to do to
make a one bit error be correctable and
this a can that got have started
famously and we're going to carry this
story on today we drew a cube and we
decorated around its vertices its
corners with all the possible three bit
combinations but I carefully arranged so
that the three zeros which I'm now using
for at three ones as Mac I put them at
the diametrically opposite corners of
the queue and what is magic about doing
that is that if there is a one error
corruption of the code you can correct
it because it is so close its nearest
neighbor matching of the bad code
against what it must have been so what
we've discovered then is that in three
bits you can have two so-called code
words bit patterns which are correctable
as well as detectable but you can only
have two
nothing else will fit the remaining
corners of the cube are needed to put
things right when it goes wrong this is
okay actually we've got a nice situation
now you send a message and you wait for
the acknowledged ill and not acknowledge
to come back so you went out with three
bit codes for four weather states and
sacrament it comes back either says
acknowledged not acknowledged but
because of this protection the actin
they're not gonna get through 99.99999%
of the time
well there's nothing wrong with that you
know as a communications protocol
because this is exactly what happens on
local area networks here we are then how
do we say we've got four weather states
but what we'd like to do is not do the
act nak protocol we'd like to send them
out with sufficient extra bits that the
far-end
Sacramento could put it right let's
assume the San Francisco and Sacramento
what miles apart you know you want to
transmit it once and haven't done with
it you don't want repeats well three
bits clearly isn't them in are three
bits can accommodate two so called three
bit code words that are distinguishable
from one another but no more and your
first thought may well be well let's try
four bits now the number of bits you use
in your code strings equates if you like
the dimensionality of the cube and we've
gone beyond cube now to hypercube this
is a topologically correct projection of
a four-dimensional hypercube onto two
dimensional flat paper there's lots of
ways to depict ease I've always liked
this one I think I saw it in Martin
Gardner's Scientific American
recreational maths column many many
years ago you draw a cube and then
inside it you draw another cube almost
sort of suspended in midair inside the
original cube you then connect all of
the corresponding corners from the outer
cube to the inner cube I've put those in
in this diagram as dots but the dots
don't mean anything
they're just something that makes it
easier for me to see the structure so
don't worry about the dots every line in
here is a projection of an edge in the
hypercube it's got exactly the right
topology but it's been distorted so that
you can understand it so here's your
challenge audience if you think visually
like this oh and by the way we're gonna
stop at four dimensions I have no
intention of going to five dimensions
when we get them to fire big codes for
damages is enough but just look at this
the challenge is to say we've got four
zeroes for once maybe as our two code
words still on the outer cube 4-bit
coding on the inner cube can you choose
any pair of corners which are not only
three apart from each other on the inner
cube but are also three jumps away from
the existing code words on the outer
cube well if I choose that corner it's
hopeless it's only one away from
existing code word even if I choose this
one up here is that any good no it's one
two away from here choose this one down
here you know is that one any good down
at the lower right no it's one two away
no matter which of the eight corners you
choose in inner cube and try and get
them diametrically opposite so maybe you
can pack in two more you just can't do
it you can't even pack in one more
because it's always no better than two
jumps away from existing code words in
other words four dimensional space has
the letters down big time but now we go
over to a much more if you like
algebraic bit pattern computer science
way and we say we will conjecture
mathematicians would say this all the
time even as computer scientists I
conjecture that five bits might be
enough to encode for weather states for
San Francisco with some sort of
protection in it so that far end can
correct
and cannot need to ask for a retranslate
and this basically is the classic
Hamming code we're gonna go against
tradition a little bit you're very used
to me putting up a bit pattern numbering
it from the right and saying that's the
zero bit that measures the ones that
twos and go right to left for
constructing Hamming code you go left to
right and you start numbering up one not
zero
okay what's special about one well in
terms of powers of 2 is 2 to the power 0
I'm sure you will all remember anything
to the power 0 is 1 2 is no exception
toothpowder is 1 2 of course can be
written as 2 to the power 1 that's just
under these another exact power of 2
here 4 is 2 squared so what having said
was this think of your positions that
are exact powers of 2 has been where you
put the parity check bits and then you
use the other bits in your pattern to
hold all the information bits and then I
will give you a methodology for working
out what the parity check bits would be
so instead of adding one parity check
bit now like we did you know in the
three bit codes we're now going to end
up adding no fewer than 3 parity check
bits I will stick to even parity nothing
special about that you can do it odd if
you want to but you must be consistent
of course ok those are out column
headings what was the state of weather
in San Francisco on the left the the
first code was zero zero if you remember
and I put the information bits of the
codes in the 3 and 5 positions where
they are not powers of 2
you've got to remember that bit 1 acts
as a check point for the positions 1 3 &
5 bit too
a check for two and bit three before up
here and the third parity check bit that
checks for five what you doing is
basically breaking down these order
numbers into sums of powers of two let's
just see if this taking up too much
space for the green let's see if the
blue works here what I'm pointing out to
you is that three can be thought of as 1
plus 2/5
in terms of sums of powers of 2 can be
thought of as 1 plus 4 so this is how it
works you write in your information bits
and then you say what about my parity
bits and you use these rules here which
effectively says that bits 1 3 & 5
taken together must be even parity well
look bits three and five information
bits Norton naught so if one plus three
plus five in parity terms and of course
lot of you realize we're doing exclusive
ORS here of ones and zeros 0 and 0 it's
even already so to keep the 3 bit
grouping including one even it needs to
be 0 bit two checks two and three the 3
is already 0 so 2 Plus 3 is parity bits
must add up to be even 0 already so
again another 0 finally what about bit
for unknown at the moment it's got me a
parity check
oh well 4 & 5 taken together must form
an even parity pair that's dead easy
what is predicted is it's a simple
binary repetition code for one of the
states okay
but everything is guided by your
information bits we're now going to move
on to zero one same rule look bit one
checks 1 3 & 5 ok 3 & 5 are in there
already
they are database a half it was 1 and a
to make the whole thing even parecer
then what have I got to do to the one
bit make it a Wang
because one and one gives you even
parity and then check out bit too bit
too combined with a bit three must give
an even parity combination while bit
threes then there is a zero so to
combine with three you've got to have a
zero and then finally bit for well four
and five
taken together must form an even parity
combination
so therefore if 5 is 1 then sorry folks
four has got to be one the next
information killed I put in there which
is the cloudy code 1 and 0 here we go
again 1 3 & 5
taken together must form an even parity
combination but you've got a 1 there and
a 0 there so you need a 1 here to
balance it off even number ones right
and then bit 2 2 & 3 taken together
well threes one we're stuck with that
it's part of the data so we put a 1 in
here to make it even and then 4 and 5
taken together that's a 0
and finally rainy here we go again
so a final bit pattern that we've got to
locate in here is 1 1 4 raining ok 1 3
and 5 taken together must be even well 1
& 1 3 & 5 that's even so keep it even by
putting a 0 in there bit 2 & 3 taking
them together well
threes a 1 so terms returned together
there be even parity must have a 1 there
4 & 5 that's a 1 so they need another
one in here to make 4 plus 5 so there we
are folks
those are our so-called code words for
all of the states of weather look at
them if you look at foggy and sunny in
how many places do the bit patterns
differ not one that's the difference not
not as much as that matches that's
different that's different
three differences their distance 3 apart
and remember distance 3 is magic we saw
that's on the cube if you keep your code
words 3 bits apart from one
then everything follows absolutely
beautifully and that works fine
we're now in a situation where we can
send all this stuff off to Sacramento
and they come blowing well sort it out
for themselves so long as you don't get
more than one error in that then fine
you can correct it by using these
Hamming codes and they say well how do
you correct it well the answer to that
is you do various simple exclusive-or
operations on these parity check bits at
the power of two positions you know like
the 1 2 & 4 position you use various
combinations of those very much along
the lines of how we encode it in the
first place and depending on the outcome
of those you'll find that some of them
check out all right yes it is even some
of them are bad and wrong and it's odd
and by combining the start positions for
the odd ones that are bad
you can uniquely homed in on the bit
that's gone wrong and if you want to
know more about that just write in and
ask Shawn and we'll see what we can do
but he had a length of two H has a
length of one so H has a distance of
three B is done right we've done B we
can count that as done so C next right
so we're here
we can't go to s we can only go to L
that's a nice easy